there's a whole lot of juiciness that
needs to be covered and that's exactly
what happened during Wendy Williams
appearance on Sundays watch what
happened fly would Andy Cohen we've got
a lot to talk about the talk show host
candidly addressed her personal life
answering questions about how she's
doing after filing for divorce in April
from her now estranged husband Kevin
hunter you and your soon-to-be ex Kevin
you two are in touch you're friendly
what we have to be you have to be yeah
Kevin jr. 20 known for 25 years yeah I
mean he messed up but you know hey
lastly Vaughn I really like the new me I
but I like her she's smart
she's strong she makes good choices I
like me when asked about her ex's
alleged infidelity Wendy used her
signature sense of humor to answer it
how would you describe your relationship
with that woman I mean I don't know who
Kevin became I don't know who I am
get out of here Andy Wendy also opened
up about her current dating life
I see many men she even shared a few
preferences when it comes to finding a
partner the youngest would be like 48
the oldest 65 would you date someone
shorter than you five feet eight only
wendy has built an entire career off of
keeping it super real which et saw
firsthand in 2014 when she opened up
about being herself and owning it
I've always only wanted to be me because
it's too hard to fake being somebody
else like and and if there's one thing
that I get delight in is when people say
oh so this on TV girl is the same off TV
girl I am and you might not get me on my
how you doing best at the grocery store
but you know what I give you that on the
show too if I'm not feeling something so
if I you know I
I'm my own inspiration
[Music]